good morning michael good
morning anna uh let me just get my
screen up here
uh where are we here okay
hopefully you can see my screen let me
audio this screen looks good to me you
have 45 minutes okay
great thanks anna good morning everybody
happy thursday it's february already
gosh this
year is going by pretty quick um
and you know even though it's only
february
honestly it feels you know if you've
been involved in the markets
this past week it really feels like you
know the markets have been trading for
uh several months this year with this
whole gamestop
silver amc stuff that's been going on in
the markets and what i want to talk
about
is trading flow driven markets and
you know in this training i'll show you
explain to you what is a flow driven
market
how you can easily determine if a market
is flow driven versus a normal
technically driven market
and last thing i'll show you how to take
advantage of the opportunity
a flow driven market provides and
you know what you saw last week with
gamestop
you know it was a flow driven market
right it didn't respect the technicals
right you know
if you've been around the markets long
enough you understand that there are
different type of market conditions
right and you can't trade every market
condition the same
you can't trade a a trending market the
same way you would trade a range-bound
market
and a flow-driven market is basically a
trending market where you have
um you know just this overwhelming flow
of
of trade of orders coming into the
market that it's just going to blow
through
levels and you're going to sit there
scratching your head saying gosh you
know
i wish i had got in earlier and you know
just really brief to discuss who i am
you know and
you know some of you guys that are new
to one of my presentations my name is
michael waltos and i've got
a 25-year pedigree
of trading at very high levels right
i've started on the cme trading floor
with dean witter reynolds
i left the floor when electronic trading
started taking off i spent
a few years on the upstairs trading desk
at dean witter then i left to join
an english trading company called the
edf man it's been around since the 1700s
after that i joined
commerce bank right the big german bank
i don't know if there's any big german
banks anymore but you know back in
those days in the 90s you know it was
deutsche bank commerce bank where they
were the two big banks in germany
and after that i joined cargill the big
american privately held
trading company that trades everything
in in the world
pretty much you know they they trade the
whole supply chain um
you know they account for about 30
percent of the grain exports of the us
and about 25 percent
of the meat exports but they they trade
you know
currencies they trade interest rates
they trade
metals they trade oil they're really
into everything and after cargill
i joined jp morgan and this was in
singapore because
cargill had sent me out to singapore to
set up a trading desk there
and after cargill i joined jp morgan as
vice president of futures trading and i
spent eight years i left in 2013 after
my daughter was born at the end of 2012.
i wanted to spend more time with my
family
and since then i've been an independent
trader and
i started order flows.com now
i've talked a lot about order flow right
that's that's my background right
because
sitting on a trading desk staring at the
market
you know on a time and sales on a dome
at the bid ask for you know basically
since electronic trading
really started taking off back in the
90s i've been watching the order flow
and when i left the firms that i was
working for and i was trading for myself
you know the software that was out there
available for traders
was okay but i realized you know
software can do a lot more
and in 2015 i released the order flows
trader which
takes the order flow in my opinion to a
whole another level to make it easier
for traders to understand
okay but you know i could talk about my
background
a lot but it's going to bore a lot of
people really the whole point of this
is about you right i want you to have
better trading results quicker right i
want you to get you up to speed on
what's the important things to look at
in the order flow as quickly as possible
now the charts and tools that i use in
this training are generated from my
flow software but what i'm showing you
today can easily be
easily be applied with other software
that's available other order full
footprint software
that's on the market you know if you
sierra charts if you use
you know the ninjatrader the basic order
flow
package or you know you use you know
motive wave or any of these others
what i'm going to show you you can use
that with your existing
order flow software if you know what to
look for if you don't know what to look
for it's not gonna do you any good you
have
the most expensive software out there
but if you don't know how to use it
what's the point
so i'm gonna show you how to use order
flow to make better trading decisions
and
you know for those of you that haven't
got a copy of it yet
i'm gonna show you how you can get a
copy of my book trading order flow for
free
if you just stick around to the end i'll
give you a link that you can
go and download it for free so
time and sales right is basically the
tape
okay it's it's showing you what's traded
okay and the volume it shows the price
and the volume traded now
actually it contains all the information
a trader needs to understand the context
of the market problem is
if you're looking at time and sales it's
like drinking from a fire hose the
amount of data that comes out is so fast
and so quick
it's gonna bury you right there's just
too much you know
we're not all born in the matrix right
we don't all don't have computer chips
in our head
to understand what's happening in the
time and sales right and you can see on
this this time in sales here
within you know seconds you're trading a
lot of contracts and
some are green trades some are you know
these
these are orange actually um but
the colors matter right because some is
trading on the bid
some is trading on the offer right and
there's quantities obviously that go
with it
but it's telling you as the market is
moving up what's being traded on the
offer
or if the market's moving down what's
being traded on the bid and that's
important information
but the problem is most people don't
know how to
use it right it's great information but
again
what's the point of having information
if you can't synthesize it if you can't
make heads or tails of it
so traders developed the order flow the
basically the volume footprint chart
okay which takes all that information
from the time and sales what's being
traded on the bid what's being traded on
the offer
and put it into an easy to read format
on your chart so you're not sitting
there thinking oh you know scrolling
through time and sales looking for
something
it's all there all right there on a nice
easy to read chart
for you so before i begin you know just
a brief disclaimer
please realize trading involves risk
right and i think we all saw that
recently with this whole gamestop
um situation right there's there's
people that made a lot of money there's
people that lost a lot of money so
you know just as quickly as you can make
money
you can lose money in the markets now
markets have different conditions
okay another way to think of it is is
like the rain right you can have your
normal rain where it's nice you know
oh hey honey come outside take my
picture i'll put it up on instagram
it's a nice weather or it could be you
know
this typhoon type rain which you know
it's like being in the shower
i've lived in asia for um 10 years and
you know the type of rain that we get
there is completely different than the
type of rain that we get
in in central uh
united states right i live now in
chicago area and
you know we don't get these typhoon
heavy rains and
you know the market's the same way
there's times where the rain is nice and
normal where it's just you know rain
showers it's nice you go outside
uh look at me i'm in the rain or there's
other times you say guys there's no way
i'm going out in that rain
now markets have the different
conditions right there are normal market
conditions
and there are flow driven market
conditions so in other words you know
think of it
like this don't make too much out of it
it's markets trending or
ranging right and knowing what condition
the market is exhibiting
is going to put you ahead of many of the
other traders who are just trading the
market one way
right you can't trade a trending market
the same way
you would trade a ranging market now
what's sort of the difference
is flow driven markets right which are
trending markets
why do they trend well they have longer
term trading participants involved
okay technically driven markets have
little long-term trading participants
involved
it's a bit like if you've ever been
white water rafting right you go down
the river
it's nice and calm you know that's your
technically driven market
but then when you start hitting the
rapids that's your flow driven market
right you you're just reacting you're
hanging on for the ride and
you're enjoying the ride so why does
participation
matter well depending on who's actively
participating in the market
is going to determine how a market
reacts right
you're not necessarily trading price oh
we traded this price i gotta react
you're trading sort of the reaction by
other traders to price so
if there are big traders in the markets
you know the ones who can really
move the market right if they are not
participating
on a particular day what do you think
the market is going to do is it going to
move very much no no probably not
right but if you can notice right if you
could pick up
in the order flow that yeah you know big
traders are active
what do you think is going to happen big
traders just don't buy and trade
you know buy and you know try to make
scalp three or four ticks or
a couple of points in the market no they
buy and hold they buy and put it in
their back pocket
and wait three months six months right
they're the ones
that are expecting the market to move
and they're buying or selling is so big
that it's going to cause the market to
move so you want to
pick up on those um that activity
when it's starting to happen right the
best time to get in on a trend
is when it's first starting not after
it's already moved
so normal market conditions now i'm just
showing you a normal bar chart here
for simplicity purposes generally
respect levels you know the the half
back level
you know the 50 retracement the 38
retracement you know fib levels
pivot points you know this yellow line
up here is the opening price
and you know you see the market come up
test that sell off come up test that
sell off
normal market conditions generally
respect
levels in the market whereas a flow
driven market
is a one-way street it just blows right
through you know the highs of the day
just keeps going higher this was the
nasdaq yes a couple days ago
right it just you know one-way street
straight up
not respecting any levels not respecting
the high of the day not respecting the
previous day high not respecting the
value area high
respecting nothing it's just going right
it's driven by flow
so flow driven markets have high
long-term
trading participants involved
technically driven markets have
little long-term trading participants
involved
technically driven markets are are
driven by technicals and who trades the
technicals are the short-term traders
right the intraday traders
you know you don't see big hedge funds
looking at
oh my gosh you know we have this level
here
i i can't trade no that's not how they
think
so who are the big size traders what's
the banks it's the hedge funds
commercials the real money accounts you
know the central banks you know people
who think
you know central banks do get involved
in the market and they are
long-term traders they buy and hold you
know they're not getting out next week
they buy they buy some more they buy
some more they don't care if the price
is going up or down if they have to buy
they buy right but their activity it
shows up in the tape
shows up in the time and sales the
problem is for most traders
they can't see that if you're just
looking at a normal bar chart right
because all you're doing is just looking
at
traded price you're not looking at
volume you know that's why traders
go to order flow charts go to footprint
charts
is because it's more useful and traders
are
able to better organize the data right
and that's really what it is
right it's about organizing data in an
easy to read format you know the
footprint chart the order flow it's not
the holy grail it's information though
right and it's information that you can
use to
maximize your trading results so
when you think of a technically driven
market right what's what is it
well it's based on technicals technical
analysis support resistance fib levels
pivot levels
etc and a technically driven market you
know is your normal trading day right if
you're familiar with volume profile or
market profile
it's the big d shape day right because
it's the market is respecting
the levels it respects the high the low
the value area high the value area low
it respects the the point of control etc
but you know what a lot of times
technical levels are are not respected
right the market just blows right
through them
and oftentimes you know traders just say
you know
when when it market isn't respecting
levels
well it is what it is you know the
market's uh it's not my day in the
markets right they just talk
chalk it up say oh you know i had a
failed uh set up here
they don't take the next step further
and try to understand that something
bigger
is at play in the market right because
what's happening
is it's a flow driven market when you
have a market that's taking out
technical levels one after the other
after the other
you know if you try to get short at new
highs
on a flow driven market
you're just going to get loss after loss
after loss just after you know
same thing for a market that's falling
right keeps falling falling falling on a
flow driven market
it's going to keep making new lows the
rest of the day
but if you're trying to trade it as a
normal technical
market you're always trying to buy that
bounce off the low
bounce off the low bounce off the low
problem is you keep making new lows
and you suffer loss after loss after
loss right you have to be able to
adjust as a trader right trading is all
about change and recognizing when the
market conditions have trade
changed and that's where order flow
comes in
okay now i'll be honest you know order
flow is not for everybody
there's people that just can't wrap
their heads around it
or there's people that are more longer
term traders
you know do they need it no you know
maybe they're more fundamental traders
okay fine
but you know for those that are willing
to take the time put in the work
you know order flow is going to be very
rewarding it's going to help them
understand the market you know today
earlier i got an email from a user just
got the software
order full software and say you know
it's really now starting to make sense
to me
right i'm finding i'm taking better
trades and
um be able to manage my trades better
so the order for footprint is going to
give you insight
into the market that you're not gonna
see on a normal bar chart
okay so you know this is uh what is this
this is the japanese yen
this is a five minute chart right and
you know the market here is is coming
down making these new lows and then all
of a sudden
you got this nice green candle up you
got um you know some
buying coming in here off the low you
know you hit the low can't go any lower
a lot of traders would see this as a
bullish sign right because why because
you're at the low
you see buying coming in right if you're
trading
as a normal a technical normal market
you're thinking okay
yeah we made the low can't go any lower
after 15 minutes this is a great buying
opportunity
but if you're watching the order flow
you would know that
you know even though this is looks like
a bearish sign it's actually not
okay and you can see this is right here
this is where the market the previous
chart i was just showing you right here
this little
green arrow right which you know it
looks bullish but it's actually
misleading you in a sense by
following price and and what's happening
in the price action
and the market just continued to drop
you know another
30 30 ticks this is japanese yeah and it
just
you know just went lower and lower or
lower but if you're trading you know oh
you know this is my
my little bounce it's starting to go
back up i finally got confirmation i got
the green candle
no you know by watching the order flow
you would know that it's actually
bearish instead
so remember okay a flow driven market is
dominated by
longer term time frame traders right
think back of what just happened with
gamestop right it went up obviously
there are a lot of short sellers
but one of the reasons why it went up is
you have and it's still up today
in the sense that you know it's still up
relative to a couple weeks ago
you have people that are buying it with
no intention to sell it
right diamond hands you know people that
don't you know they're long-term
traders and
generally you know other than this
recent gamestop stuff
the long-term time freighters are the
really big money in the market
and they don't respect technical levels
right they don't think oh my gosh
this market's too expensive i can't buy
it here because you know
uh relative strength is is too is
you know off the charts um you know or
the markets
overbought you know they people
understand that market can go from
overbought to more overbought to
moreover
more overbought to extremely overbought
to you know off the richter scale
overbought right
big bankers they're not thinking oh you
know we're coming into a support level
i'm not going to get short here flow
driven markets just blow right through
these levels with impunity
right you know people don't say well you
know we're we're at this you know
all-time high
i can't buy here or you know taking out
yesterday's high i can't buy
here flow driven traders they just buy
it you know they've got orders to fill
so what are levels well there's sport
resistance there's daily highs and lows
there's overnight highs and lows there's
big levels there's pivot levels there's
so many different levels you can come up
with
um you know it's funny because i was
joking with somebody about fib levels
they're big fib traders and you know
what's
they as i was telling them yeah i trade
because they're like well i trade a 987
tick chart or you know
a 6 12 or 5 12 chart and stuff i'd be
like well i trade the 629 chart
wow 629 what is that some hidden levels
no it's my birthday june 29th
um you know some of these things
sometimes
it doesn't make much sense so how do we
know like this is the chart i've shown
you earlier
the footprint chart how do we know that
this is a good opportunity
to get short all right right off this
this high right because
now you finally got some buying coming
into the market shouldn't you
be looking to get long
and some traders are going to say that
this is what happened
prior to this this chart i just showed
you you know some traders are going to
say well the market has been selling off
uh it's been trading lower but honestly
that's a lot of monday morning
quarterback right it's it's easy to look
at a chart
after the market sold off and look for
reasons you know it's a bit like bitcoin
bitcoin goes up people look for reasons
on why it went up
after it went up or if it goes down 20
percent in a day they come up with all
these reasons why
it went down after the day as a trader
you got to make your decision now
right you can't do after the fact
trading you know when you're at lowe's
of the day
you got to be asking are we going to go
lower or is this it
is this as low as we're going to go and
we're going to start to rally
now this area here right
in the box right so this is the bar
chart just sort of give you an idea
yeah the market had been trading lows
hit the low and then went sideways
now it's sort of coming back down to
that low is this low going to be made
and people say well
it's obvious right you look at this
chart it was just going down down down
it you got to sell it right this is what
happened in that box
afterwards right yeah the market just
sold off another um
30 ticks okay well
it's easy to look at a chart and after
the fact and say well yeah obviously
we've been selling off
right you come down here you got to get
short again
well the day before a couple days
earlier we had sort of the same thing
market traded from the high of the day
down into the lows of the day
but it didn't go lower in fact it
rallied rallied up to
new highs of the day so
you know it's one thing to look at a
chart after the fact and try and
um analyze it but in real time you know
as
a trader you've got to be making that
decision in real time
you can't trade a chart after the fact
and go back in time
and and trade it that way
so what made this a great short
opportunity well
if you're looking at the order flow okay
every time there was aggressive buying
on the low of the day
it couldn't build on it there was very
little continuation
now in order flow we have what we call a
divergence now there's bullish
divergences
there's bearish divergences i'll get
into the details of those
in a second but down here right this is
from the open
we traded down into the lows we had two
bullish divergences which should be
bullish right the market you would
expect to rally because what's happening
you're at the lows of the day
and you see aggressive buying come in
okay
what does the market do it just goes
sideways are traders getting rewarded
for their effort no
everyone's coming in buying this low but
they're not getting rewarded because the
market's not going anywhere
so when we come back to that low right
here we have another divergence
okay so now you have this is your third
divergence
okay and most traders
are expecting a rally again because you
have divergence you know technically you
should be buying right you got
aggressive buyers coming at the low
now they're doing it again but the
market doesn't rally instead it sells
off and this is a trade
setup that i always use to define a
trending market
okay and we'll get into the details the
specifics about it
in a second but by the time we hit this
third divergence
i'm already looking to be getting short
right because i've got a lot of bullish
information in the market
but i know the market's not rallying
okay because
who's buying it off these lows well it's
a technically driven market
uh traders you know the short-term
traders that oh we're at the lows i got
is i got to buy it right that's
how people are trained to do you know
you buy lows you sell high and if you're
trading at lowe's
that makes it easy for you because
you're at the lows of the day
so remember who moves the markets right
well it's not just
markets just isn't just made up of
buyers and sellers right it's made up of
aggressive buyers and aggressive sellers
the traders who
lift the offer or sell into the bid now
there's also passive buyers and passive
sellers people that work a bid
and work and offer so you got to
understand there's even though there's
buyers and sellers you have aggressive
buyers you have passive buyers you have
aggressive sellers you have
passive sellers and all this information
these different types of traders
show up in the time and sales when a
trade is
executed but it also going to show up in
the footprint chart
now you and me we're small traders right
as you know we're not going to move the
market no matter how aggressive
we are okay there's always going to be a
bigger trader out there
that's going to bully us and don't get
bullied
just follow what they're doing right
follow
the big guy that's going to move the
market right but more importantly you
want to follow the big size aggressive
traders now let's pause okay
because let me get into a little bit
more advanced stuff for you guys
there's three building blocks of order
flow there's delta
point of control and imbalances delta is
the difference between aggressive buying
and aggressive selling
the point of control is the price level
in the bar with the most volume
and then there's imbalances which is
when aggressive
buyers outnumber aggressive sellers by a
certain ratio usually it's four to one
but you could adjust that
or more and vice versa okay so you got
to understand
some of the data that you're being able
to use from the order flow
in your analysis and divergences deal
with delta so delta is
again it's the net difference between
aggressive buying and aggressive selling
in a bar when someone
aggressively buys right they buy at the
market they lift the offer
that registers as plus one in the delta
if they aggressively sell at the market
so if they sell the bid
if they sell at the market that
registers as minus one
now every bar has a delta it could be
positive it could be negative it could
be zero
right when it lands on zero it's just
more of coincidence than anything else
um the strength or weakness of the delta
gives traders
a clue as to what's happening in the
market right now right remember you
gotta trade in the presence
so delta right most software workflow
software
will show it on the bottom all right and
you can see here this market was going
down yeah we got negative delta which is
what you expect on a market that's
moving down because
it's showing you sellers are in control
but now you start seeing
positive deltas which technically is
bullish right you're at the lows and
you've seen
aggressive buying coming in right you
see people coming in lifting the offer
at the low now sometimes it could be
short covering
or long liquidation depending on your
highs or lows
um but you always got to be paying
attention to who's in control of the
market
so how do you spot a flow driven market
in the order flow well you look at
divergences
okay now there's different types of
divergences there's bearish divergence
there's bullish divergence
a bearish divergence in the order flows
is when you have a new or equal high
with negative delta so you're at your
high of the day
but you have aggressive selling coming
in imagine you're at your high of the
day
if you're expecting the market to go
higher you want to see aggressive buying
not aggressive selling
a bullish divergence would occur at the
low of the day
right it's when you have a new or equal
low but you have positive delta you have
aggressive buying coming in
at the low so
you know think about it right and
there's somebody i know
a few years ago that they they thought
they discovered this the holy grail to
the market you know divergences well
you know you're at the height of the day
and you see and if something comes in
right aggressive selling comes you got
to short it
well sometimes yes sometimes no
okay and it's important that you have
software that's going to highlight that
to you
to show you when you have a divergence
in the market rather than sit there and
try to analyze the market bar by bar
there's a lot of information
the market is giving you have software
let your software show all this
information to you so you can make the
decision you spend your time
not analyzing every trade that comes
through the market but rather
tell you what's happening based on that
trade and let you
make the decision now the order of
illustrator software my software
i recognize that this was important
piece of information and my software
highlights that to me
when there's a divergence in the market
so that i could sit back and say
let me now take this divergence and put
it it in context
of the market okay so this is our
japanese yen chart again
so we got a few bullish divergences here
as you know the market opened up here
you have a divergence right on the
you know in the same bar that you open
but then you got a divergence and then a
little later you got two divergences so
i know that you know we sold off now i
got some aggressive buying coming in
and that's bullish honestly okay
now a bearish divergence is the opposite
right you're at the highs of the day
and you have aggressive selling coming
in so you can see here right these two
bars have
this down triangle which tells you
there's bearish divergence right you got
the high of the day
you got negative delta the high of the
day you got negative delta that's
aggressive selling but as you can see
the market didn't do anything he said it
just made new highs
well you know you say mike you just told
me that
if i have bearish divergence the market
should go down
but you're just you're showing me
examples where the market's going up
right and it's
sometimes easy for traders to get
confused because they just take things
at face value
you got to put it in context of the
market and there's an important saying
is you know what doesn't happen
in the market is oftentimes more
important than
what does happen as expected so you know
what doesn't happen as expected is as
important as when something
expected happens so if you're expecting
the market to go down
based on your analysis and it doesn't
does that mean you're wrong well
partly yeah you're wrong but it's also
telling you it's giving you a very
important piece of information that hey
there's something bigger at foot
in the market right you could analyze
all you like but
if the market's not doing what's
expected it's probably telling you
there's something else going on in the
market that's that's much bigger than
your technical level or um
you know your analysis is leading you to
believe you know everyone likes to say
well you know all the information
available to traders is in the market
well
it's not you know there are people have
access to information that you
and i and many other traders just don't
have and and will never have
now what i want to talk about though is
you know the flow driven market and how
you could recognize it so
you know you have a divergence and it
should either be bullish or bearish but
when you get start putting together
strings of divergences that are failing
that's a sign right this is a sign that
the market may be a flow-driven market
so
what i like to look for well i don't go
out of my way to look for i just see it
on the chart is
when there's two divergences that are
violated you know two divergences that
happen relatively
s you know soon within um you know of
each other
i'm watching for the third divergence
because if that third divergence is
going to get violated
chances are the market's going to run
so this was here this was the third
divergence right here
okay so i had two earlier back here it's
not on this chart
that failed okay because the one was a
little higher
next one was on the slow of the day now
i'm coming down here i got another one
okay what i'm looking for you know i
just put in a stop in
right here i'm not looking for this
market also in a rally you know if it
does great
but what i'm looking for the market's
got a stronger propensity
to break down okay so i know at this low
of the day here
you know this market keeps pounding down
okay
every time we got the aggressive buying
coming in it's not enough to move the
market
and then look what happens right it
breaks through that low you got the
heavy use volume of the day
you got a very strong negative delta so
you know aggressive sellers are
definitely in control
you simply put a buy stop or sorry in
this case a cell stop
because we're at the low you know right
below this low of the day to get into
your trade
let the market confirm that yeah you
know what it's flow driven
there's bigger traders at the home
that's going to
move the market you know just go along
for the ride
now this was the e-mini chart the other
day
okay so this is 10 30 chicago time right
i've got a
divergence here well 1033
another divergence you see the market
starts to come off doesn't comes back up
makes a new high another divergence
aggressive selling coming in
you got negative delta so i know there's
aggressive selling but the market's not
going anywhere
you know traders that are selling it
here aren't
getting any reward for their effort
right they're just
selling it maybe they're taking profits
but there's somebody that's
happy to buy it right market makes
another new high
up here another divergence so i've had
one two three divergences
in a span of about what is that about 20
minutes
okay so at this point i'm looking well
if we're going to break
61 and a half 62 that's where i'm going
to be looking to get long
because now i know i've had
reasons to be shorting this market that
are not working right the aggressive
selling is coming in
after we make these highs but the buying
is just too much
right people are getting run over
right so you see this was the third
imbalance here
right here right this one right up here
at 37.61 and a half
does the market move well it starts to
go off a little bit right it's come it
comes off from 61.5 down to 54.
okay it's a nice
six-point move seven-point move it's
just hanging around
right you got aggressive selling but
it's not really strong enough to move it
anywhere so but i'm still interested you
know if we're gonna come back up here
i know i've had aggressive selling but
it's not enough to move the market down
very much
if we're going to come back up you know
i think it could be off to the races
and what did it do it came right back up
here 61.5 62
shot all the way up to 77.
all right buying on the breakout of the
third failed divergence
all right you had first divergence here
second divergence here third divergence
here
i'm just sitting here with i just put a
buy stop in here okay
comes in fills me trades immediately you
know all the way up to 66
66 and a half it comes back how much
heat did i take on the trade if i'm
getting long at 61.5 or 62
it only came back to what is that 59 and
a half
two points of risk for what a
15 point winner
so flow driven markets they tend to be
more fundamentally driven
right technical levels are being driven
over see what i did there driven
they're not being respected these
technical levels right the high of the
day is not being respected why
because long-term traders long-term time
frame traders specifically
they have orders they need to fill right
they don't care about the high of the
day or the low of the day
what you're seeing is clear price
direction
okay here's crude oil yesterday or the
day before
the second february 2nd right divergence
divergence divergence
54.75 okay
now i know this one failed
this one failed i'm going to be watching
see if this one fails
right i don't have to get long
immediately i mean you could always buy
a dip
but you know for me it's a little safer
just i put my buy stop in here at 76
okay it comes back up here takes out
that high i think i've got a good
opportunity for
a nice trade and what happens
boom it takes out the failed the third
divergence
right here okay then it puts in another
couple divergences
see the market doesn't do anything it
doesn't really sell off
you know you're getting long at 76
you're risking what is that five six
ticks
right for what long at 76 you can see
just moved all the way up to 91
but a bit later all the way up into
the 55s 5510 5520
all the way up to 55 you know 26. i'm
not saying you'd sell it right up here
but you know you
you're getting long in here how much
risk are you taking you get a little bit
here he pulls back a little bit here
pulls back a little bit here even a
little bit here
you know oftentimes there's a lot of
traders would sort of inverse this chart
you know imagine and i know a lot of
traders that would get short up here
and you know it's trading 90 they don't
get out thinking it comes back down here
to 70
you know their entry price 75 they're
three ticks four ticks in the money
thinking this trade is finally going to
work comes back up here
again ah okay i'm in the money i'm not
going to cover it you you want to be
above this blue line long rather than
short from above this blue line this is
the third breakout right here this is
where it happened
the breakout on the third failed
divergence now here's nasdaq
again on the first of the month a couple
days ago divergence divergence
divergence
so 13 197 and a half right
i know this is my level i just put a buy
stop in here at
97 and a half 97 three quarters 97
or sorry 98 okay i'm looking for the
market to keep moving because why
because i'm looking
i'm thinking that okay maybe we're in a
trendy market
a flow driven market that there's maybe
something fundamentally i don't know
that's happening in the market
okay boom boom boom
you get a 70 point rally off that and
that's just all by looking at
divergences in the order flow now
earlier you had a 70 point pullback here
okay before it started making these
highs but you didn't have any
divergences there
you know maybe at these divergences
people are
looking for a 70-point pullback like you
had here but instead
as a trader you should be adapting to
what's happening in the market and it's
telling you there's bullish
flow coming into the market if we take
out this
third divergence chances are it's just
going to keep going up and up and up
so hopefully you can see how order flow
delta specifically
divergences gives you vital information
as to what can happen
next in the market but again you know
delta and divergences these are just
parts of the order flow generated
information
okay you can look at other information
like imbalances and point of control
but using order flow is like having a
treasure map right now it's not going to
give you the exact route but it's going
to give you the route to
know where you should be going in the
market it's going to give you a better
understanding of what's happening in the
market
and what separates winning traders from
losing traders is not having an edge
edges come in many forms right it could
be a piece of information that other
traders don't have or something
they don't recognize or something they
don't see happening in the market
order flow gives you that edge because
you're going to have information other
traders
don't have you can be able to see things
happening in the market that that
they're not going to be able to see like
a market sweep
you know or um and stacked imbalance or
you know a lot of things or market
weakness
so hopefully in the last 40 minutes
you'll agree that this has been time
well spent honestly i can't cover
everything in you know a quick 40 minute
training session
but i've got a special offer so you get
everything you need to know about order
flow
and if you act fast i'll give you a
special deal okay
it's the order flows trader software
right it's
in my opinion the best order flow
software available to a user
now i admit i'm a bit biased now it runs
on ninjatrader eight
doesn't run on trading view it doesn't
run on tradestation
and what it is is the volume footprint
chart you know the charts that you saw
in this presentation are generated
from my software so you can see where
there's a divergence in the market
okay and that's just one of 17
pre-programmed
order flow tools right i could
do 17 16 more presentations on just each
unique
order flow tool in the order flow trader
software right that's just one of the
divergences is just one little bit of
um what's available in the software and
it's very easy to set up on ninjatrader
takes
a couple minutes basically imports the
software into ninjatrader you don't even
need templates
because the software defaults are set up
to my defaults
and normally i sell this for 8.99
but it's really like the way to describe
it is like taking
my knowledge of trading order flow and
putting into a programmer
so you can see what the big traders are
doing in the market right i spent 20
25 years trading at very high levels on
the institutional level
what i did in the markets is being
translated
into my software but i realize
having software is one thing you got to
know how to use it
and i give you access to a bunch of
education i don't just say here's the
software go figure out overflow on your
own
no because you won't you'll be the waste
of your time
so what i give you is education right
you give you
access to my order flow trading course
there's 20 lessons
normally i sell this course for 297. you
can get it for free
you also need access to my inner circle
video series which is 56 videos on
advanced order flow analysis
tips tricks um on reading the order flow
and normally i sell this for 4.97 you
can get that for free
so the software the training the and the
inner circle access
you know that's sixteen hundred dollars
almost seventeen hundred dollars but
you're not gonna pay that
but again you know i realized that you
know it's one thing to watch courses you
know watch videos
what you want is some action right and
each week tuesday nights 7 p.m central
time i do a weekly live group training
where you can come in ask questions
about a specific market about something
about the software
and i'll answer that with you so you
know even if you say well you know mike
nebrase's emails
every week you're invited to this and
you could attend so
you know say you sent me an email and i
missed it right you could
come in here and i'll address your issue
sometimes you know people buy software
then you want to talk to the guy they
charge you access for that i mean what
what's that about
so you're going to learn more about
order flow in these weekly sessions than
you know you thought possible right
because it's one thing to watch videos
you know that came out a couple years
ago what you really want to know is
what's happening right now in the
markets
what's the best form of analysis that
you can use to understand the markets
so you know if if you add all this
together you know the
the software the training the weekly
live training you know it's
almost nineteen hundred dollars almost
two thousand dollars but
you're not going to pay that it's just a
one-time payment of 7.49
what you're going to do is you're going
to go to order flows dot com
slash off three right and
it's only going to be 749 dollars
there's no more weekly
payments that you gotta make you know
monthly recurring payments as some of
these software's out there
you know they want to bill you forever
you know make you a customer for the
next 10 years of paying
99 200 a month no you know it's just
7.49
a lot of traders say very nice things
about the software
you know and how easy it is to use and
how you can see what's happening in the
market you know sheila says you know
the software order flows trader software
is very helpful i can see
what's really happening in the market so
what you got to do
you go to orderflows.com off three
scroll down takes you to this
the button down here click this button
to get started go to orderflows.com3
takes you to paypal i don't get your
paypal information i do realize right
once you pay the information gets sent
to your email that you use with paypal
and if you don't get it you should also
check your spam folder you know
sometimes people
forget to check their spam folder or
they use a different email address for
paypal than their regular email address
i don't know your regular email address
is different right it goes to your
paypal
address but i also give you
the order flows playbook right which
also has additional trade setups in
there right normally i sell that for 297
you're gonna get it for free today so
get started now go to orderflows.com3
that html i put the links in the chat
there's no monthly payments or anything
like that
just a one-time payment to get started
so what you're going to get is the order
flows trader
software trading courses order flow
trading course oracle's inner circle
video series
the order flows playbook and you get
access to the weekly
live group training and if you can't
attend due to
time zones that's fine it's recorded and
you'll get access to the recordings as
well
so if you want my book go to
orderflows.combook.html
enter your name and email address and
then click submit the next
page after that will take you to the
download so you can download it to your
phone your computer etc
so get started right in life you gotta
get started
right so go to orderflows.com3.html
the links in the chat so anna i'm going
to
throw it back to you guys you know if
you've got any questions just
you know send me an email mike
orderflows.com and i'll do my best to
get back to you in a timely manner so
anyway anna thanks for having me and we
got two more great speakers coming up
after me
so thanks everybody thank you so much
michael
great presentation thank you
let's move to our next